we are pleased to have in our studios
Thomas L Friedman the Foreign Affairs
columnist of the New York Times
welcome back Tom great to be here great
to be here at my favorite website
globalization I was wondering if you
could tell me about the new version of
your book world is flat well I'm coming
out with the 3.0 edition which will be
out in August
it'll be paperback final um and I've
added I would say three major sections
first is it I redid a chapter on kind of
rules for business operating in the flat
world and it really built it on what I
now consider to be the iron rule of the
flat world and the iron business rule of
the flat world that applies to more than
just business I would argue is is this
when the world is flat whatever can be
done will be done the only question is
will it be done by you or to you that's
the only question your place or
somewhere else exactly because when the
world gets this flat it means that when
when so many people have this much
connectivity and this many distributed
tools of innovation and collaboration if
you have an idea 9 promise me you'll do
it because someone is Slovenia will
because there's too much education too
much knowledge too much connectivity and
too much distributed tools of innovation
too much in inverted commas I think it's
wonderful so that whatever can be done
will be done and then what I do is
actually give a whole set of examples of
the incredible mix of matching
combinations that people are creating
out of nowhere to create global
companies I give you one example I say
South Sioux City Nebraska I talk about a
company out there that imports the
machine from Korea that makes prefab
walls along with the insulation makes
the insulation in the wall together
evidently there's a great efficiency in
that they then sell this machine decoite
okay well that in itself is interesting
I was South Sioux City Nebraska they
import them they have some doodads they
sell them to Kuwait but I ask them how
do you communicate with the Kuwaiti oh
very interested in South Sioux City
Nebraska there's an Indian tribe called
the Winnebago Indians the Winnebago
Indians have a casino as many American
Indian tribes do call wina Vegas
Vegas casinos spun off all kinds of cash
so the Winnebago Indians used some of
the cash to start a development company
part of the to provide employment for
young Indians one of the things they
started was an ad agency the ad agency
of the Winnebago Indians writes the
Arabic brochure getting an Arabic
speaker obviously to help them to for
the South Sioux City Nebraska company to
import the machine from Korea to add the
doodads in South Sioux City to export it
to Kuwait that's someone who understands
that whatever can be done will be done
and they're doing it is not just
anything that could digitized it is
actually real matter exactly it's both
you know
atoms and electrons and digits basically
and so you I've got a lot of examples of
I talked about the Indian outsourcing
company Satyam one of the big Indian
outsourcing companies which has begun a
program through its foundation actually
where maybe a major American company
like GE outsource works to outsources
work to Satya
Satyam now outsource as part of that
work to Indian villages because they
discovered that there's a there's a end
of that work that is is relatively
simple but it can be very high value ad
for an Indian villager there's enough
educated personnel now in Indian
villages you know it can be 5,000 people
and enough technology that the outsource
II can now become the outsourcer so what
what's actually going on in the world 9
and I think I'm not sure economists have
fully captured this is they're these
incredible very individual mix and match
them combinations that people start
individuals or small groups are doing
and I think it's actually driving the
global economy and a lot more small
business than people realize corporate
driven yes but what you are telling me
is that it is driven by a lot of people
individuals and small companies exactly
one of the lines I have in the updated
version of the book you said we tend to
think about competition is competition
between countries or competition between
companies when I'm actually saying is
when the world is flat the biggest
competition is between you and your
imagination it's really between you and
your because if whatever Ken
be done will be done the biggest
competition is between you and your
imagination to imagine what can I do
yeah
and this idea that's all multinationals
it's all you know big corporate well
that is going on but the other is going
on just as well because the
infrastructure through which this
transactions take place requires a lot
of investment but the multinationals can
test where they come in and and in this
world have no doubt the big can act
really big and really small you know
there's a wonderful
I had actually an ad for UBS you know
Bank my stock brokers at UBS I was
calling him on the phone one day and he
I was put on hold and so I'm just
listening there's a loop of an ad going
over and it says I think I've got this
right UBS our offices are everywhere and
right next to you and it's this idea
they can operate globally but also
really micro locally and serve you as an
individual and so the big connect really
small in the flat world but the small
connect really big and and the same and
both are happening now in the picture
you present is that it is really growing
and becoming more intensified yes and
yet from judging by what we did on the
American press there is a growing
concern that this is going to lead to
more and more job loss and recently I
think Wall Street Journal had a piece in
which it courts Alan Blinder
the former Clinton economic advisor as
saying that up to 40 million job the
American jobs may be lost because of
outsourcing and that is a very important
piece of news in an election year so how
do you see this panning out why the Elms
onto something I mean Alan someone who's
in my experience in conversations with
him has understood the implications of
the flat world as well as any if not
better than any other economists and
he's understood that when when this much
work can be made fungible digitized that
it will go wherever it can go it'll be
like water it'll it'll find its natural
most productive and efficient point in a
flat world and I think that what Alan's
contributed
the discussion is actually a very
careful analysis of every job and and
even slices of different jobs whether
it's lawyering you know or financial
services or design and saying you know
this slice now is so so digitized about
shred of it is tradable exactly now and
that means if it can be done it will be
done 15 job yeah I mean it's very very
interesting what he's done and I would
urge people to look at that so so the
question then is what does one do to
cope with this simple job loss
especially of the middle-class or
educated class which is new in America
blue-collar jobs have been lost since
nitrogens but this is something new well
the key thing is to know what world
you're living in and one of the things
I've done in the updated version of the
book in the 2.0 version I've added now
into 3.0 is what I call the new middle
we know what the old middle-class jobs
were a lot of those were blue collar
jobs you know but what are gonna be the
new middle jobs so I think there are new
middle jobs and I actually created a
category not a list of nine they're
broad categories they aren't you know
architect for Novell you know software
whatever but broad categories that
really should people should think about
as they think about the job market and
if you can fit into one of those
categories you're gonna be fine
excuse me now at both ends they're jobs
that are going to be fixed so at one end
our people are really special and
specialized okay Michael Jordan JK
rowling your brain surgeon no problem
they're safe they're not going to be
outsourced to digitize and the other end
of people localized and anchored okay
your butcher your baker your candlestick
maker this cameraman here till they get
a robotic camera okay so they're all
fine all right but in between a lot of
jobs that are going to sort of come in
and out of what I would say the middle
class and as you think about them you
want to be in one of these categories I
go through them very quickly I know if I
remember all nine off the top of my head
but great collaborators that's what
people can collaborate over 24/7 create
leverages people who can leverage
technology so one person can do the job
of 20 rather than 20 doing the job of
one
great localizers people who can take the
power of the flat world and create a
local small business out of it that's
like the eBay entrepreneur or the sports
bar owner who suddenly discovers he can
have 20 flat-screen TVs in his bar and
have curling from Sweden and figure
skating from Japan he doesn't have to
just have NFL Monday Night Football
great this is gonna be your salvation
and hopefully mine great explainers
because when the world gets this complex
whether you're a manager teacher
professor a real estate agent who can do
modeling there's gonna be a huge huge
demand for people who can explain okay
great adapters people who are simply
good at adapting to whatever new I build
all these around individuals new
technologies you know that come along
another category math lovers math is
gonna be so important because in a world
where everything's digitized that means
everything's been reduced whether it's
words photo data spreadsheet to ones and
zeros well if it's all in ones and zeros
what does that mean it's all analyzable
by algorithms and that's why of course
Google is just an algorithm but so many
ad advertising campaigns marketing
campaigns will be built on math now
rather than the intuition necessarily of
someone so there's me huge great
opportunities in math one another
category I call passionate personalized
errs oh if you can bring a passionate
personal touch to any new middle job it
won't be outsourced or digitized I build
that around a guy who sells lemonade at
Camden Yards Baltimore Orioles Stadium
and he doesn't just sell the lemonade
night he doesn't jig he does a dance he
sings a song stands on his head high
fives you always noticed at the end of
the game night he's got a wad of tips
ten times thicker than anyone else in
the stadium because he took a vanilla
job selling lemonade at Camden Yards
which is water sugar with a lemon
floating in it doesn't get any more
vanilla than that and he put a personal
passion to touch on another category
nine anything green tell your kids
anything green because when the world is
flat and three billion new consumers
walk on to the flat world all with their
own version of the American Dream House
a car a toaster a microwave and
refrigerator if we don't find a cleaner
greener way to power their aspirations
we're going to burn up choke up heat up
and smoke up the planet faster than even
Al Gore
predict so what does that mean it means
green design green consulting green
manufacturing green science is going to
have a huge new middle opportunity in
fact that's one area of why perhaps
globalization actually you've come to
help clear jobs because this global
concern about climate change is creating
the condition where priority is given to
the climate aspect of any venture and
this opens the possibility for
innovation and new jobs that didn't
exist before well you're always on to
things dying you're always ahead you're
always right on the cutting edge okay so
I've just finished a magazine piece for
the New York Times gonna be out April 15
called green is the new red white and
blue and we've got a documentary version
of it coming out on the Discovery
Channel on April 21st Saturday night at
9:00 p.m. and one of the points I make
is exactly that you know what I build it
around the story I build it around GE
Transportation GE Transportation is um
that sounds like a bland name it's a
company located in Erie Pennsylvania
middle of the American Rust Belt
okay Erie Pennsylvania nine has a trade
surplus with Mexico and China they say
how could that be middle of the Rust
Belt that's those are made these are
blue-collar jobs okay how is that you
know what gee transportation makes makes
choo-choo trains makes locomotives okay
but you're GE transportation sells
locomotives to a railroad country called
China even though China has a locomotive
product that is 30% cheaper because of
its cheap labor than GES how is that
because GES is so energy efficient on a
total operating cost basis it can
out-compete the cheap labor Chinese now
now if you go to GE Transportation what
John's mean their manager will tell you
a set looks like a dilapidated old
factory inside he says we're in
knowledge campus because green now
becomes a value the only way you can get
green is by PI enormous amounts of
knowledge what do we have what is our
value at we can apply not cheap labor
but knowledge to things and when green
comes a new value the ability for us to
apply knowledge to it becomes a huge
competitive advantage and that's what
people need to understand yeah the other
aspect of globalization which is that
globalization is actually making people
far more aware of the issues of climate
change Danny it Rob the other as
possible in fact the story that you
recounted recently a column or the TXU
company that is actually perhaps worth
telling our audience well there's
actually two things that globalization's
there are three things one is the flat
world is bringing three billion more
people from low impact environmental
lifestyles to high-impact environmental
as they buy cars refrigerators and
microwaves so that is intensifying
climate change from China from India
from Brazil okay that's going on on one
track but another thing that's happening
is people are also becoming aware it's
one world it's not that China is my
backyard the EPA the American
Environmental Protection Agency has
concluded that 25% of the polluting
matter in the air above Los Angeles on
some days comes from Asia comes from
factories in China or desert if occation
and sandstorms kicked up in Asia and
brought over by atmospheric winds but
the last thing that's going on is as the
world gets this flat social activists
environmentalists who want to bring
pressure on bad actors now have enormous
leverage to do so and that is the story
of TXU the Texas Power Company that said
we're gonna build more coal-fired power
plants that we're gonna build 11 in your
face pal and I've got the governor of
Texas Rick Perry who's approved it
that's what DX you did well turns out
that Kohlberg Kravis Roberts a big
buyout firm and TPG another buyout firm
decided they were gonna buy TXU and they
put forty five billion dollars on the
table basically thirty two million and
about thirteen billion in debt
assumption and the whole deal was held
up whole deal was held up nine by two
people who had no money on the table
environmental defense and the national
resources the Natural Resources Defense
Council who were brought in by the
biases of NGOs these are NGOs
environmental NGOs who were brought in
by the bar
who said I don't want to buy this
company because you environmentalists
have been using the internet to run a
campaign against him and we don't want
the trouble so we want to buy this
company and they had a like a - almost a
marathon almost day long negotiation at
the Mandarin Hotel in San Francisco to
sort out the whole deal and the people
whose approval was made the deal
possible were the only two people who
had no money on the table the two
environment they had the power of the
Internet they've been power of the flat
world and the internet that they could
leverage and the buyers did not want to
take on that power the same thing is
happening in for instance with Starbucks
Starbucks is a different company today
than E to us any absolutely
oh my god yeah that it's morning - and
that's one of the new chapters actually
have in the book the chapter is called
if it's not happening it's cuz you're
not doing it and it's really addressed
to young people it's about social
entrepreneurship and activists and
basically saying look with when the
world's is flat you care about an issue
whether it's helping the poor or
stopping genocide in Darfur well if it's
not happening it's because you're not
doing it because you can do it
you could be organizing a website you
could be organizing a web campaign you
could be tapping a global constituency
and mobilizing it for your cause if you
do it if you've got merit on your side
and and and can make a compelling
argument so if it's not happening it's
because you're not doing it and the
chapter is built around a bunch of
examples around that I've got one other
new chapter which is called what happens
when we all have dogs hearing and what
it's about is in some ways the flip side
it's about a world where all these
individuals are blogging podcasting
youtubing creating their own content as
individuals and search is getting more
perfect at the same time Google
technorati com now what happens that in
a world where everyone's creating their
own content over here and search is
getting more perfect over here what it
means is if I can go to I can go to
Google now and I can put in nyan Shanta
hit I'm feeling lucky and I can see
everything written about you I can see
everything blogged about you on
Technorati dot-com
what does that mean that what it means
is we could
all now we could all now hear everything
whispered about us what does that mean
we all have dogs hearing and the social
implications of that are going to be I
think profound I've written a chapter on
that as well yeah that that is something
going to come as the as Internet spreads
right now about 100 million sorry every
day how would a billion people are
connected right out of six billion so
it's still 1/6 of the world is connected
yes
and as the internet spreads the dogs
here in fact we're getting more and more
you're gonna be able to hear everything
whispered about you yeah the the other
question though tom is the invention
therefore therefore is a kind of tragedy
which is looks like the world cannot do
anything about it yeah and now what's
going on in Zimbabwe yeah so how as if
as an international observer of
long-standing how do you see these two
countries getting away with murder
how is it possible in this literally
getting away with murder and in some
ways it's it's a part of the flatworm
some not when the case of Sudan it has
this resource called oil China I think
is the biggest shareholder in this
national Sudan oil company are one of
them and and so Sudan hides behind uses
that and the threat of cutting off these
all contracts or just the leverage that
it enjoys from that in order to by
itself protection and then you have all
these sovereignty issues oh my god you
know and so this is a case where it
seems to me Africa should be taking the
lead and and it's not and should be
basically saying to Mugabe you're out of
the club what you are doing to abuse
your people what you Sudanese government
are allowing by way of mass murder in
your borders simply puts you out of the
club and and there is no there's no free
pass because of sovereignty I think it's
got to start with Africa doing that
Lord doors if African did that the whole
world would pile in but if Africa is not
ready to
that if it's ready to do the opposite
South Africa has been protecting Mugabe
we know that you know and the Arab world
has protected Sudan and prevented a UN
mandate you know now yes we the United
States could could fly in troops and and
conceivably stop this genocide but you
know given what's going on in Iraq now
that's not likely to happen
yeah the u.s. ability to actually act in
the world has been critically
circumscribed if you remember that when
Colin Powell called what's going on in
Sudan is genocide yes in all the times
the u.s. pronounces a country right
performing genocide that would have a
huge impact look what's going on today
you know as we as we speak 15 British
sailors have been abducted
Iran claims they strayed into Iranian
territorial waters and we're snatched by
the Revolutionary Guards and they're now
in in in Tehran maybe it'll be resolved
maybe not but that's gone for a week now
and what really strikes me watching that
story has two things one is 9 if I ever
get abducted please don't call the EU to
help me out okay
um here's here's here's Great Britain I
mean there remember the EU and why are
they fighting this alone I mean to me
within 24 hours the EU should have had a
high-level meeting that's said to Iran
either let these guys go or you know
we're going to end economic will ban
will freeze all economic relations or
all diplomatic relations with you that's
number one
I mean either the EU feels the Iranians
are right that the Brits you know
straight into their waters so either the
EU believes Iran over Great Britain or
they don't care about piracy but it can
all be one or the other so please don't
call the EU if I get in trouble call
I'll call somebody else and and the the
other point I would like to make though
is on top of that is that I don't think
a lot of this would be happening if
America weren't so weak and in people
down you know what you're seeing is is
the impact you know all the Europeans by
the way they always care about rule of
law multilateralism where is that in
this case where where's the multilateral
sponsz to what Iran is doing but um I'm
afraid part of it also is the the fact
that you know the Europeans always
worried about too much American power
now you're gonna see a world of too
little American power and that really is
something very awesome that's very good
it's unipolar warlin and that one power
is filling Hubbell exactly which is
which basically the in relation to the
Rogues right and the Rogues are more
power than ever because of the price of
oil yeah and so it's a very bad equation
that the good guys and I think we are
the good guys are weaker than ever
because of what we've gotten our hobbled
how we've gotten hobbled in Iran and and
the bad guys are stronger than ever for
the wrong reasons and not because of
their making microchip is because
they're sucking oil out of the ground
you know yeah that's not healthy yeah
but only think perhaps looking the
future is that that oil is one day going
to run dry yes well look into the future
is two things one can be hopeful for one
is a rising Indian that will be more
assertive because India's a democracy
and it does share our values and I would
like to see Indy become more of a
stakeholder more voice in managing the
international system with us I'd welcome
that and I would say the same of China
you know China talks about its peaceful
rise rise to do what where you when when
Iran abducts 15 you know British
soldiers in international waters at
least Britain's claim are you slamming
your fist on the table saying let's have
a Security Council meeting are you
lecturing your on we we alone can't be
the stakeholders of the international
system and we need other you know other
the big responsible powers to do that as
well not happening right now yeah I
think the question of China is really a
critical one because China on the one
hand is clearly a major player in the
world in all senses except in political
example exactly China is shrinking away
from expecting any political role
they're big everywhere except in taking
responsibility yeah and so how do you
get China to do that yeah is the big
challenge for the Western democracy ya
know if you do a graph about China
here's the graph of exports here's the
graph of imports here's
graph of resources you know it's it's
looking to extract around the world
here's the graph of China's responsive
you know taking responsibility for the
international system yeah and if you
just think maybe before we end the
situation in the Middle East the Saudi
Kings comment that British American
presence in Iraq illegal has been kind
of quite a striking departure from the
past yes how do you explain this well
you know he did make that comment at the
same time as the Saudis issued a new or
restated their peace overture to Israel
and my guess is he was balancing his
books with his own constituency on the
one hand making the peace overture to
Israel again renewing the 2002 overture
and at the same time slamming the
Americans on Iraq that's my guess I
don't know but 9 it underlies a real
point for me and why I've come to the
point in my own writing on Iraq well I
believe we do need to set a date to
leave because right now everyone around
Iraq has choices except us oh the Sunnis
can cooperate with us or not the Shiites
we can cooperate or not the Saudis we
can tell you you can't leave but in
public your occupation is illegal okay
we are
everybody's protector and everybody's
target okay everybody's protector and
everybody's target and that's a
situation that is intolerable and the
only way to flip that is for us to say
here's the date we are leaving you want
to work with us we want to work with you
you don't know we have choice okay
because you will have to pay
unequivocally the impact of us leaving
so you will give a debt in order to
pressure people to realisation that
Americans are actually see we're leaving
and I know they're bad guys who
applauded yeah we won okay but there are
a lot of other people are gonna have to
recalculate all their positions because
right now everyone's assuming that we're
just going to hold up the bag and when
we do that we allow everyone to pay
retail
boots art we allow everyone to pay
wholesale for their position don't you
want you want your position you're going
to pay retail for it now because we're
going so we're not really subsidizing
difference between wholesale and Risa
retail so that's that's basically well
so what what would be your sort of debt
you know I don't you know a year eight
months I I said everyone home for
Christmas two months ago you know now
obviously we will have to leave troops
on the borders of Iraq will have to
create safe zones we have a moral
responsibility to rocky's who have
worked with us but the more you read the
news from Iraq the more it is obvious
this is a civil war and it's a civil war
at that early stage where both sides
think they can win and therefore we
rather than being the broker are seen by
both sides as the obstacle to their
victory
so rather be seen as the broker who can
actually manage the deal we're seen by
both sigh if only the Americans would
get out of the way we could have it all
and when you're in that situation
tragically unfortunately you have to let
people just basically find the balance
of power but I don't think we can just
you know walk out of Iraq I think we
need to get out of the way of that
conflict though and say look if you guys
you don't want to fight it out go ahead
if not we'll be happy to draw the
borders but we do have to create safe
zones we do have to give your rockies
green cards we have a moral obligation
to not be the sponsors of a genocide
there is in November 2008 so that almost
gives them deadline absolutely that's it
for but and it is a deadline in another
year what I worry about is that push has
an exit strategy for himself but not for
the country and see what what what Bush
I believe was trying to do is get Iraq
at a low enough level of violence where
he could turn it over to the next
president without looking morally
irresponsible ok Iraq is not going to be
resolved in 18 months surge or no surge
you know it's not even going to be
self-sustaining it is if everything went
well but Bush wants to get that down to
that level where he can turn it over and
not have to say I presided over the
failure with helicopters leaving the
embassy and I don't think we have enough
people there to do this I don't think
you're gonna be able to do that I I
don't think you're gonna have anything
even approaching self-sustained I don't
I don't
know what's going to happen but I'm
dubious let me put it that way that this
is going to work I I hope it does I hope
he's right but I think that's his game
because he does not want to come - if we
come to you know Election Day 2008 or
post-election and Iraq is burning like
it is today and he just leaves it to the
next person that will be a damnable act
you know so he's got to decide before
and I think the country is going to
decide and I think most importantly who
I'm looking forward to decide night is
the Republican Party they will make the
decision Republicans running for office
aren't yeah but you know we have to hope
for the best you know what's going on in
Iraq is tragic and the people who are
winning winning you know are the most
anti modern anti-democratic it's dealers
these are these are nothing but Neela's
and that that's what breaks my heart is
someone who really hoped this would work
that we could implant we could
collaborate with Iraqis to implant-- a
foundation of democracy in that part of
the world which I still think is so
important but we are up against an eel
ISM there nine that takes your breath
away with reading the paper coming up
this morning people loading ambulances
and blowing themselves up you know in
people reloading food trucks with
dynamite and blowing themselves up as
people gathered around to get food
people blowing up schools universities
this is Neil ISM like we've never liked
I certainly I've never seen I should say
in a in any other context yeah this is
this is indeed a the most the greatest
moment in the moment it's just because
if this breaks out and it's a it's a
tremendous challenge for the Muslim
world because also worried we're reading
the paper coming up I saw there was a
suicide bomb in Pakistan today so this
is spreading now it's spreading as a way
to solve problems you solve a problem
with someone suicide bombing and what's
so problematic about that night is that
suicide bombing is it's very hard to
defend against and because it's so hard
to do because every person is a
potential bomber you're a potential
bomber the cameraman is a potential
bomber when that's the case that's the
end of open society
because if everyone's a potential bomb
then everyone else has to be a potential
policeman and and that is a huge threat
to open societies
well treatment thank you very much for
your thoughts my pleasure now great to
be with you again